peu
[Musique]
e
moi
[Musique]
e
ehret et oui c'est comme ça maintenant
le monde à l'envers j'appelle ça les
méthodes nouvelles de rééducation
pénitentiaires à bombay france quoi est
aussi jouent leur petit harding
aujourd'hui on aura tout vu et oui mais
où
[Musique]
bonne nuit quand même merci monsieur on
va essayer
joyeux noël
bien
on dirait la voix du 27 maintenant non
ça c'est pas le 27 annoncé ça c'est le
vieux jojo le condamné à mort sur wii
écoute
ah oui par exemple 1
[Musique]
précieux l'église est déjà fermée oui
c'est déjà fermé papa c'est complet bon
même enfin si tu t'es absolument
entretien à une bijouterie là bas tu
vois et battu casse la vitrine qui colle
fait derrière l'attitude droite met au
chaud
[Rires]
[Musique]
elle et lui
jours
[Musique]
les mots
m
[Musique]
mais le bie
en chantant tous on avait
[Musique]
oui
oh
[Musique]
attention attention dangereux criminels
dénommé série neige s'est évadé de la
maison départementale déguisé en père
noël
je répète en père noël attention il est
permis
[Musique]
la musique la voix du sénateur mais ça
ne se passe pas comme ça
[Musique]
oh
jamais encore un
sinon qu'est-ce qu'on peut au palais
ducal du mas rouge
[Musique]
le chercheur n'avait pas vu par hasard
un père noël un peu bizarre un père noël
plus tard enfin on va dire un drôle de
type qui avait l'air s'enfuit vous savez
monsieur l'agent père noël est toujours
un peu bizarre
puis je vous dirais que ma femme et moi
nous sortons jamais la nuit quand il
fait froid plus rien finalement
excusez-nous novembre et au soir
[Musique]
riez pas
voilà
[Musique]
par ici
qu'est ce que vous dites l'épaule père
noël par hasard ont peur d'aller plus
fort je suis dur d'oreille
le nom d'eric lazarevo à vue le jeune
gardien russe mir 2 attendu non plus je
n'ai entendu non plus je suis en train
de faire voire un million en décembre
ml oui mais que doublé ses protégés
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
et
où
hu
[Musique]
ma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hall vient s'ajouter hier maman regardez
moi il m'a fait tomber mais non et
martin voilà des manières pour un père
noël mais surtout dans une chambre à
coucher et après tu sais quand une map
pour angers fait loin toujours moi à
l'époque
qu'est-ce qu'il faut commencer vraiment
i want one pourquoi il n'a pas porté la
baignoire que je voulais pour marquer sa
part si molex
je sais pas les tudors forcément tu es
fatigué
qui l'eût cru
quand ils sont arrivés je te donnerai
une spéciale de faire marquer
aum
au petit chat mauvaise
babin
bonjour tu as bien dormi sur un ennemi
et toi tu as soif brabois
la demande ou même à moins de deux mois
mois
tu es fatigué war tu veux pas voir maman
bonjour je cherche à bois le duc d'york
que tu passeras pas tout point que je
serais pas là
autre information
un calme on a arrêté dans une baignoire
d'eau dit merci et bien combattu non
c'était si qu'y trouvera-t-on vers dow
jones avait reculé déjà dix ans forment
joue pas avec de l'eau grenier si ton
père noël a soif et la dernière voilà
que dis je veux pas abba et nador un
père noël doit toujours donné vol
exemple là et que son père noël laisse
là dedans je préfère qu'elle croit au
père noël plutôt qu aux histoires de
brigands de moi ta mère tu pas ma mère
c'est ma maman c'est toi qui a pris le
pistolet
monde en noir
tu t'appelles comment
je veux dire à papa un coup de biens
france
je suis un père noël qui est tombé du
ciel
et en tombant je me suis fait mal tu
comprends le savent pas encore là où il
faut les prévenir
donc ils viennent me chercher c'est ça
un hélicoptère il m'emmènera
oscillatoire voulu
tu m'aimeras il ya un hélicoptère demain
je comprends il faut que tu me prévienne
le bon dieu tu vas bien
ah oui voilà chercher le papier la barre
toi
mon
je me
pointu
écrire toi oui tiens c'est que pour moi
a écrit
je suis blessé puis 6
dans le grenier régner
qu'est ce que c'est ton adresse ici
un long de la rue et pas le numéro sais
pas
une rue gilbert n'avait rien eu
rue jules verne attention
impressions
c'est habité
bébert
mme hébert ouais bon dieu comprendre
c'est mon petit nombre mais bernie est
bel et bien écrit qui à bientôt écrit
oui je vois
la concession
sans rien dire à personne
et tout un pieu paulo paulo c'est le
facteur du bon dieu est confiante et les
beats over 10 des sports la gare à
israël est tout seul tu te rappelleras
pôle haut var deux pas de la gare répète
[Musique]
je dis à personne
oui je le répète à personne en france
au pistolet
voilà ton petit coin
[Musique]
où
on vient voir paulo
[Musique]
bien servi à 100 balles
tu vas porter ça en face au mal
[Musique]
oui la mode tout à l'heure alors
on vient pas dans ce cas là c'était
peut-être un message de bébert
[Musique]
hop
ce petit set mais ce n'est pas ici je
vais te montrer moi tant que doit
apporter les endroits des cas de vente
de l'alcool
ben quoi
[Musique]
et
what du billet
j'oubliais que tu as apporté au bar tout
à l'heure qu'il avait donnée et willy
[Musique]
l'amour
tu sais quand je cherche partout au
papier du papier ça normal monsieur
l'agent je suis sorti un peu
précipitamment je les ai oubliés chez
moi bon suivi - audit moi je vous
remercie beaucoup
ce n'est rien l'essentiel c'est d'avoir
rejoué procès quand même au commissariat
on sait jamais avec des types au
commissariat est ce que tu te rends
compte de ce que tu as fait te sauver
comme ça à six ans et demi
c'est du propre c'est pas de ta faute si
on lui avait pas pour être avec les
histoires de werder brême
voilà c'est ça c'est notre faute
maintenant notre fils va au bar des
sports était tout ça normal on mange ta
soupe match et les gars prendra fin de
l'an c'est le père noël il ya longtemps
qu'il a tourné au ciel
[Musique]
ma
où
[Musique]
de tout le cabinet
nous avons permis
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
non
[Musique]
viens nous voilà une personne n'est pas
parce qu'ils restent ainsi tu vas fait
ma démission
oui
qui a trouvé le bar des sports oui mais
[Musique]
non c'est pas encore l'heure du goûter
regardez-moi sainte-croix alors qu'elle
l'emmène exemple un livre à moi ça sera
clair c'est à tout pour tout le monde
parce que mon père noël pour moi est bon
oui quel valable puisque leur manoir
je ne suis pas un fan assisté quand on
voit leur a fait dix ans qu'on les
prenne mes côtés
[Musique]
te voilà parmi son allure ça leur fait
une demande pardon si tout ça mais je
m'appelle allègera n'arrête pas d'avoir
soif il m'a même pas mal
[Musique]
comme chez monde
à ce moment là voyant que l'autre ne
répondait pas il lui redis encore plus
fort monsieur vous êtes une banane dans
la règle droite et loga se retourne sur
une espèce d'imbécile n'y voyait donc
pas que je ne peux pas vous entendre
j'ai une ballade tendre à droite bon ok
ce client amd hanafi la tétine dans puis
la nuit tout ça depuis que le père noël
est passé à ça elle le voit partout elle
ne pense qu'à lui depuis qu'on lui a
fait voir que le père noël existe et on
a bien du mal à se débarrasser de lui on
a eu la bêtise de lui dire que le père
noël avait été l'un des greniers
je me demande si à l'époque moderne on
ferait pas mieux d'élever les enfants en
leur disant la vérité sur tout y compris
sur les mystères de la vie
ça le rend ces mots on se le demande
aussi aux non ça c'est mignon quand tu y
croies manger cru jusqu'à huit ans
maintenant avec toutes ces machines il
ya plus de poésie dans la vie mais alors
si ça doit les rendre malades
moi je ne marche plus je vous écoute moi
bien maintenant tu es une grande fille
je veux te parler comme une grande
personne autrefois quand tu étais encore
un tout petit bébé je te raconter des
histoires de père noël mais c'était
seulement pour rire qui veut pas dire
que le père noël n'existe pas tu te
souviens qu'on a vu dans les grands
magasins qui servent à prendre des
photos raconter des histoires mais leur
barbe elle est fausse ce qui tire dessus
elle s'en va
ça veut dire que le père noël qui sait
c'est un monsieur
c'est un monsieur comme moi comme le
papa de christophe comme monsieur
gosselin quand tu arrives noël qu'est ce
qu'il fait
j'irai lui acheter le petit chat qu'une
réclame depuis si longtemps salut
changera les idées pour y eut quand on
les attache ensemble on a le sens répété
encore et vous écrire sur votre feuille
à eau est attachée une vous avez le sens
où florence
[Musique]
non
la fin
attendez vous
pour y adhérer parents moi qui n'est pas
loin
je suis pas vrai ses parents sont là
c'est pas aller chercher à boire
nous pouvons
caire
voilà donc un appareil est important
oui
je mets tout capté chose
très peu compte dans ses rangs
comme ça je te plaît oh oui là tu vas le
chercher un peu d'eau
on met à pleurer toi qui l'a fait points
comme les bataves et les mains on va
déjeuner
qu'est ce que c'est je te laisse jadis
hyper de la soif et la came here bois
dans la cuisine
oui me tombait fier ton père noël est
très un peu allez viens je lui l'iran
[Musique]
par les bras
bon alors vous êtes père noël mélina
il est pas con
tu vois bien repartie voir au ciel il va
vite mais quelque chose tu va camper
froid ici tu sais florence
j'étais comme toi quand j'étais petit ma
grand mère aussi me raconter des
histoires et à chaque fois je crois dit
que c'était pour elle mais elle s'était
pas des histoires d'eau qu'à noël
c'était plutôt dès ce soir
frigant
[Musique]
deux histoires de brigands des histoires
riant ce que j'avais bonjour lines on
vient pour l'arrosage ravanas oui un
petit coup de temps en temps jean-pierre
bien voir en fait
à la nuit vers les filières
l'environnement mais qui vous envoie
assurez vous y arrivez à la pdc pour la
sécurité piquemal on se chauffe avec
précités aux autres monnaies nous les
faisons nous pas tous les moyens de non
non non rien rien rien du tout elle est
lourd s'est dit là
[Musique]
allez minette attendait une chape mal
élevés en ange dans le grenier
[Musique]
parce que la tête soit depuis huit jours
afin de demander à manger c'est toi
qu'on inscrive tous les jours au grenier
mais les mecs comme un coucou à la scion
faire dévisser le jour comme ça que ça
commence on va lui donner un peu dur
jordanie que j'y vais bonjour monsieur
c'est la raison harrison et compagnie on
vient pour débarrasser votre collier
foot et gris on les rachète à prix d or
un labo de nous en aller comme un non
sens parce qu'ils sont non dira encore
j'en ai trouvé train de grimper sur le
toit avec l'échelle d'ivey pour vérifier
la boutière bien celui que j'appelle un
agent pour qui les gravissent ne pas se
laisser faire
non
car il n'y avait personne à personne
elle dit citée par ansa le pape polonais
altéra
durant un service père noël
tu m'as trahi atomique du passé je parle
de bernal de fer tian ce billet tu veux
chez l'épicier tu l'achètes un autre vin
rouge doit rapporter si le truc à
personne
il ya quelque chose pourquoi dans ma
chaussure m'apporte empilables m dommage
tu avais demandé d'apporter une
baignoire
pour martine dieu que ce sont quand
martin a coupé la connais pas c'est là
sur six chapelles bien bon tu auras ta
baignoire
en attendant tu vas aller chez l'épicier
et touche et ravins et en même temps tu
prendras un camembert
alors après tu auras si le boulanger et
d'une demandera une baguette de pain un
ca compris
[Musique]
ce que tu peux leur faire chanter pour
la terre alors c'est un monde ce samedi
tout seul à la maison voilà les bêtises
tu commences à faire passer le goût du
père noël pour mary bale dans l'embarras
mais alors tu veux pas me diane keaton
billets etc ou bien un jour le père noël
ça fait longtemps qu'il est remonté au
ciel tu as bien vu quoi lorsque tu es
allé au grenier avec maman et avait
montré que le père noël à des parties
alors ce biais il vient d'où bon et bien
puisque c'est comme ça je vais aller
fermer à clé la porte du grenier - étude
montre que lorsque je leur ai dit toute
la vérité
allez mon avantage vilaine fille à leus
du vin que bien sûr qu'ils te demandent
pas un business dans son porte monnaie
j'ai tenté trois fois dans l'année oui
mon n'est pas du sport avec les voisins
en plus elle s'est fait d'années à
camembert trop fait pas ça c'est pas
grave moi même
martin son mari des bienfaits enfin on
boira
[Musique]
elle est vite il faut décocher un
la séance a commencé mais le grand final
pas à 9h20 c'est permanent annonce d'un
film policier tu vas pas me faire rater
le début bien yves
[Musique]
on
hier
ils m'ont fait confiance et je me suis
dit moi je serais pour les x alors comme
ça c'est son père qui a sifflé la
bouteille de pinard je t'ai envoyé
chercher avec mes choux ben c'est pas
comme s'ils nous attaquent
j'avais gamin camembert aussi financier
martin il est bien fait bath mois le
pâté à temps
[Musique]
je vois
et maintenant qu'est ce qu'il fait il
commet des délits soit venir horizon on
se referment et reprise mais alors ça
c'est une des grosses acquisitions de la
transformation du lait maison de
rééducation c'est qu'on a supprimé tout
ce qui est barreau tous les prisons tout
ce que le monde carcéral à deux shows de
subjuguant créant moins envoûtant
c'est moins envoûtante et plus froid
c'est plus difficile l'un vit cependant
les enfants revenir sur les greens on
est content quand même pas empêché des
enfants de s'attacher à la maison où ils
ont senti que à peu près des cinq
personnes qui n'est connu jusque là
désinv
[Musique]
de pétards
c'est pas toi manger ça dans le monde
[Musique]
anvers
nous
[Musique]
oui
voilà vous êtes sûr absolument sûr
martin sommes partis hier soir au cinéma
vers 9h10 florence dormait nous avons
bien fermé la porte à clef derrière donc
ça je me suis certain
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas dans la
cuisine que nous avons dîné mai dans la
salle à manger
c'est ma femme qui avait débarrassé la
table je me rendrai vers minuit ça rend
à sedan mais toujours et le frigo était
vide
bon ben ça alors vous êtes sûr on n'est
pas fou tout de même à tout ce qui reste
du poulet des os pour ça alors quelle
affaire hebbadj au fait ça veut dire et
qui a mangé le bouhlel pâtés saucissons
fromages de gênes basse et le tarn one
ça recommence
qu'est-ce qui se passe 1 qu'est ce
qu'elle mangeait tout ça ne veut pas
dire internement le duo mois
est ce que c'est encore
ah là là les enfants quels soucis en
tout cas demain je l'emmène chez
spécialistes vous devriez l'emmener au
dispensaire alfred binet bausch amoureux
il paraît qu'ils ont des ars là bas
[Musique]
allez viens ma chérie ma cabine et non
je vous disais d'entre deux chambres ont
été très contents de ces spécialistes
elle avait sonné ligue 2 et pipi au lit
à bord il fait plus maintenant six
mètres en inquiète plus donc
regardez donc ce que j'éprouvais fixe à
savoir
bessane dans la vendre il est monté ce
team a disparu de la wii
vous êtes
ça va
c'est une des photos
[Musique]
un temps record
s'amuse plus moi je condamne le grenier
si elle fait si à peu les pompiers de
roncq à me demander la clé
et
[Musique]
à
le
[Musique]
bon